we have reason to believe that they are
engaged in a false flag operation they
have an excuse to go in
why would you do this well in order to
create an excuse for action and this
instance a justification
[Music]
russia plans to manufacture a pretext
for its attack
we don't know exactly the
will not present here a baseless
accusation saying that russia allegedly
was going to attack ukraine
current western approach around the
ukraine crisis has been trying to
preempt everything the russians could do
but certainly it would be quite
astonishing to think the russians would
escalate in ukraine without some kind of
short-term food take some kind of
justification
[Music]
false flag operations and attacks appear
throughout military history probably the
single most famous incident is in 1939
the very start of the second world war
in which the germans
falsified an attack by alleged polish
border guards
in september 1999 nearly 300 people were
killed in bombings apartment blocks in
moscow and other russian cities
after the attacks
doubt was cast by a number of insiders
that actually the russian authorities
had fabricated the attacks to create the
justification for this second invasion
controversy still ranked over u.s
involvement in vietnam war but there is
actually an alleged false flag incident
at the start of 1964
by the famous gunport tonkin incident
[Music]
oh